some schmuck on msnbc thinks that there
is
an idiot percentage of the population
and according to him
the people who make up that idiot
percentage
just need to be told what to do i think
it was a lot harder the first time
around to because we're you know we're
creating new behavior versus returning
to kind of behavior we've already been
through
so look whether it's a mandate or mask a
mandated vaccine
is at this point there is a percentage
of the population that
who cares whether they're angry or upset
about that this is just there's 330
million people in this country we need
to protect ourselves
as and as as willie and alicia mentioned
look there's there's been
mandates on throughout time i grew up
having to get smallpox vaccine we all
did
on the vaccines also so i'm done
worrying about what people think i'm
done
worrying about is there going to be a
firestorm whether it's a mandated mass
whether it's a mandated vaccine
there's an idiot percentage of this
population that just needs to be told
what to do and guess what you don't have
a choice too
bad you know i i think that guy has a
point
i that guy is most certainly convincing
me
that there is an idiot percentage of our
population
that would be our ruling elite i don't
think our ruling elite
knows the first thing about philosophy
or politics or life
generally i think that the regime that
the ruling elite
has foisted upon us has led to misery
in basically every aspect of life
and i think that that idiot percentage
ruling elite
needs to be told what to do by the far
smarter
far more grounded far better adjusted
people
to whom that elite pretends to be
accountable i'm michael knowles this the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday is from cool papa j
magic
who says what a great name says joe
biden will solve the inflation problem
by printing more money ibram ex-candy
will solve
racism by adding more racism yeah that
makes sense
where do we find these geniuses great
point
you know these people these are the sort
of people that probably go into the
brick and mortar
auto parts store instead of just going
straight to rockauto.com
why would you ever walk into that brick
and mortar auto parts store
when you can just go to rockauto.com
order the same parts online
save a ton of money not have to answer a
ton of ridiculous questions about the
make and model of your car
questions that if you're anything like
me you probably won't know all the
answers to
and then you got to wait because the guy
is going to go into the back they're not
going to have the part they're going to
order it online at rockauto.com probably
anyway and then charge you twice as much
don't do it
rockauto.com is a family business
they've always got the lowest prices
possible
rather than changing their prices with a
bunch of gimmicks you know tuesday
in the morning it's going to be much
cheaper and it's 30 off on wednesday no
it's just always reliably low
same prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers
the website is so easy to navigate that
even i
can do it head on over to rockauto.com
right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck and then write knowles know w
l e s in their how did you hear about us
box so they know
that we sent you these people
who are part of the ruling establishment
the ruling class what do i mean by that
i mean
the people on all the legacy media
outlets not the insurgent new media
outlets but all the ones that are
established that have all the
gatekeepers that are promoted by the
regime i'm talking about the people in
big tech
i'm talking about the people in the big
highfalutin positions of power i'm
talking about the people entrenched in
the federal bureaucracy
i'm talking about the democratic party
which is the demo the dominant party in
this country
right now it has unified government but
it is just molded with
the entire elite apparatus i think these
guys
maybe should take a take a seat for a
moment
i think i i think for them to doubt our
intelligence
is pretty rich what say you mr president
that's underway
just like the other question is
illogical and i've heard you speak about
it
because you all i'm not being solicitous
but you
you're always straight up about what
you're doing and the question
is whether or not we should be in a
position where
you uh um are why can't
the the the experts say
we know that this virus is in fact
uh um uh is is it's going to be
uh or assuming we we know why all the
drugs approved are not temporarily
approved
but permanently approved that's underway
too i expect that to occur quickly well
that
means you mean for the fda for the fda
well
oh gosh i'm sorry i need to catch my
breath from that dizzying intellect from
the genius percentage of the population
that rules us and by the way i'm not
even just making fun of biden
biden has always been you know a few
a few french fries short of a happy meal
joe biden has never been the brightest
bulb in the pack
not quite the sharpest tool in the shed
how many more metaphors can i use
historically i mean joe biden is
famously
not that bright but it's not just him
and obviously he's senile now so he's
he's even slower than he used to be it's
not just him i'm not just taking a cheap
shot at joe biden who
who should not be president and is
obviously not capable of
of being president it doesn't matter
though of course because he's just a
vessel
of the ruling elite he's just a vessel
of the establishment
i'm talking about the establishment
itself we have had
roughly a century or so now of
almost continuous liberal rule of
progressive liberal rule beginning with
i guess more than a century then
depending on how you count it
beginning with woodrow wilson
revolutionizing the federal government
admitting that he was doing it while he
did it saying that our old
constitutional order is outdated we need
a new order that's going to empower
progressive technocrats
you see fdr really begin to implement
that and you see it ratchet up over time
even when there briefly were periods of
relative conservative rule
they didn't succeed at impeding the
growth of that federal
technocratic elite even ronald reagan
famously complained
or rather lamented that he he did not
manage to shrink the government
so this thing has been growing and
growing and growing over time and in
recent decades it's really accelerated
what has that given us
because you see the growth in the
government but then you see the radical
transformation of society the sexual
revolution
all of these sorts of things what has
that given us
birth rate below replacement where
people are not having kids
a decrease in life expectancy recently
because of deaths of despair
you're seeing a plummeting in the
happiness of women both
relative to men and as an absolute
measure
you're seeing spikes in child anxiety
and stress and suicide
you're seeing a complete gutting of the
middle class you're seeing manufacturing
jobs shipped overseas
you're seeing a total loss of control
over even our own border
you're seeing a collapse in the faith
that we have in our institutions
including in our electoral system you're
seeing
abject failure on just about
every single front in our society
and yet these people who have ruled
basically without challenge for a
century
are telling us that we're the idiot
percentage of the population
just give them more power just listen to
those geniuses a little bit more and
things will go so much better
are you seeing that is that what we we
no longer can keep men out of the little
girls changing room
but give the geniuses more power that's
that's what's going to help us out
what i'm talking about when i mock these
people
who have the audacity to call the rest
of us idiots i'm not just talking about
joe biden
losing a few synapses i'm talking about
the whole
system which is both inept and
extremely corrupt just look at a little
bit of this corruption the doj right now
you probably didn't even see this news
story because it was
dropped very quietly and the media
aren't going to cover it the
establishment media
you recall that governor quovid in new
york andrew cuomo who was fetted as the
great
savior of coronavirus he won an emmy for
his performances which were
fictional performances over how
wonderfully he was handling kovid when
he
released a book the media thanked thank
you governor
and then it turned out he was he was
handling the virus worse than any other
governor in the country
he not only sent thousands of senior
citizens to their deaths because of his
bone-headed policies
but then he covered it up from federal
investigators so
there was at one point an investigation
into what cuomo was doing
but now joe biden's justice department
is formally declining to investigate
those nursing home policies not just in
new york by the way so cuomo is going to
get off the hook
but also in pennsylvania and michigan
places that had come under scrutiny for
the way that they were treating their
senior citizens
that's dropped that's over now no big
deal no one's you'll you'll hear about
it
on this show you'll hear about it maybe
on a handful of other conservative shows
and that's it and it's going to be
memory hold and quovid is going to
going to go sell more books and he's
going to get off the hook like i told
you he would by the way
do you remember when the when the sex
scandal came up which
i observed from the very beginning was
just a distraction from the real scandal
which involved kovid and lying to
federal investigator
covering up things from federal
investigators i said cuomo is a tough
guy
if anyone could survive this it's going
to be him well he's going to survive
we just we should just listen to them
more kill a few more thousand senior
citizens how about biden's doj
on the chinese spies you probably didn't
even hear this story
so the department of justice was
prosecuting
five visiting researchers from china who
were just academics just scholars but it
turns out they were spies for the
chinese government as is often the case
so the wall street journal uh just
reported this weekend
that the doj is dropping their cases
against the chinese spies
why because it turned out that they
weren't really spies no
why because the spies
fulfilled their justice they dealt they
endured some criminal justice and then
they were they were going to be released
no
they just dropped it quote in all our
prosecutions the department of justice
evaluates the merits
of a case as it prepares for trial this
is doj spokesman
wynn hornbuckle which is not a real name
right there's no way that that is
actually that guy's name this is
this is like know spies will often come
up with
elaborate names this has to be that in
any case mr hornbuckle says
recent developments in a handful of
cases involving defendants with alleged
undisclosed ties
to the people's liberation army of the
people's republic of china have prompted
the department to re-evaluate these
prosecutions
we have determined that it is now in the
interest of justice to dismiss them
right because the trump administration
uniquely among administrations over the
past several decades
took a hard line on china said the
growth of china is not good for the
united states it's not good for the
world
obviously it was correct because just as
trump was getting tough on china
whoopsy daisy a virus leaks out of the
wuhan lab that shuts down the entire
world looks like he was right
joe biden who famously cheered on the
rise of china is now cozying up to them
again
he won't call china an enemy he won't
take a hard line on them
so he's dropping the prosecution into
their spies surprise surprise and no
one's going to hear boo about it
and that's that's just that did we
elicit any concessions from china
i don't think so it's just over just
listen to the ruling elite listen to
those geniuses
maybe we'll shut the world down again i
guess we already are for the delta and
the lambda and the phi beta kappa
variants
when you want to stand up against these
kinds of bullies
it helps you know to have nice swarthy
skin a nice
lean sort of physique nice baby face
such as but if you can't have that one
way to appear intimidating
is grow a beard which is why i would
strongly recommend you check out beard
supply
if you are one of the many men who are
currently growing a beard or maintaining
a beard chances are you're in need of
products to keep it looking
thick and healthy you don't want some
scraggly
hideous looking thing make you look like
a stray dog no you want a nice
lush beard you do not want to show up to
your neighborhood
outdoor barbecue in the blistering heat
without a bit of beard oil to keep your
beard in check
go visit beardsply.com for a limited
time only you can buy one beard oil
product and get another one
for free head on over to our friends at
beardsupply.com today
you order yourself two beard oils for
the price of one by the way you can mix
and match different scents
you can stock up with an old classic
whatever you choose make sure you choose
beard supply hurry up while there's a
deal last
go to beardsupply.com buy one
beard oil and get another one for free
and be the toast of your neighborhood
barbecue
our brilliant ruling elite is not only
disregarding
our immigration laws these are some of
the most
fundamental laws in our country who gets
to come in and be counted as an american
but our ruling elite is now inverting
those laws and saying that
foreign nationals who cross our border
illegally
not only can they one day become
americans not only can they stay here
first of all
and not only can they one day become
americans but according to kamala harris
they already are i want to make clear
to the dreamers who are here and those
who are watching from home
this is your home this is your home
and we see you and you are not alone
the president and i needless to say and
i hope many of you saw his town hall
yesterday
we are unequivocal that we recognize you
for the americans that you are
and that we recognize that you deserve
all the rights that come with american
citizenship
and so we will be tireless in fighting
for a pathway to citizenship
hold on kamala why would you have to
fight for a pathway to citizenship if
they're already americans
according to kamala harris not and it's
not just her again i don't mean to just
pick on her according to the entire
liberal ruling elite words no longer
have meaning
if foreigners are americans then words
have no meaning
if men are women then words have no
meaning
if we can no longer rely on language to
make
basic distinctions between a thing
and its opposite then
words don't have any meaning but what
the left believes as i
i think i read somewhere in a recent
number one national bestselling book
the left uses language they believe that
because there's no such thing as
objective reality
therefore words do not refer to any
objective reality
but rather words construct and
constitute objective reality subjective
reality i guess
and so if you redefine all the words you
can redefine reality so
if you want to make a foreign national
into an american you don't
need to have them follow the legal
channels you do not even need to
undertake any legal process
you just call them americans and then
they are americans
if you want a man to become a woman he
doesn't need to well it's impossible
but you you don't even need to go
through the surgery
to have the man better resemble a woman
you just need to call him a woman and
then he just is a woman
and that's that these are the geniuses
see we're the idiot percentage
who believes there's a distinction
between foreigners and americans
citizens of another country and citizens
of this country we're the idiot
percentage
but kamala harris who fails to recognize
the most basic distinctions in politics
she's the genius if you oppose illegal
aliens by the way
illegal immigration and then amnesty for
breaking a basic law
you will be called a racist right that's
just that's the worst thing you can be
called in america today and that's what
you will be called
i touched on this at the very end of the
show on friday but i don't want to miss
it
the girl scouts girl scouts of america
are now pushing on the little girls who
make up the membership
an anti-racist guide ant
anti-racism these derivations of
wokeness and critical theory and
critical race theory
are now have now infiltrated the girl
scouts the girl scouts told its
membership that
taking a color-blind approach to life
where you don't really care that much
about
what race a person is that actually
perpetuates
racism and parents must have
conversations about race and racism
regularly with their daughters to
counterbalance this narrative
this is part of the online resource to
push anti-racism
and critical race theory the guide goes
on to say
saying we're all the same or i don't see
color
might be well-intentioned but it
perpetuates racism because it disregards
part of people's identities plus saying
everyone is the same implies that
everyone has the same experiences and is
treated the same in our society
which statistics and the everyday
discrimination faced by black people and
other people of color show isn't the
case
so you're saying it's wrong to say
that everybody is the same because that
erases people's identities
and denies their suffering now notice
though
notice if you were to say okay fine
everyone is not the same not everyone
has equal ability
okay yeah uh every everyone's not the
same
not everyone has equal intelligence not
everyone has equal ambition
not not everyone has equal uh moral
cultivation
not everyone has equal virtue in the way
that they live
you would be sent to guantanamo bay
that would be so outrageous that would
be so racist or sexist or this sister
that is
but if you
say not everyone is equal not everyone
is the same
because not everyone suffers as much
well that's that's the only thing you're
permitted to
observe about differences in people
because
suffering now carries social currency
suffering is the new privilege and so
this is why you have ever expanding
victim groups and this is why everyone
is trying to claim some kind of
oppression because that
paradoxically will actually give them
privilege
the reason i mention this is we've gone
over this kind of ideology plenty of
times on the show just
just to point out that our ruling
liberal elite
which as the commenter on the show
actually says is going to solve racism
with racism
it's going to solve inflation by
printing money and solve racism by
adding more racism
this ruling class has gutted not only
our constitutional system of government
our educational systems
our corporate systems are
it's gutted civil society even the most
basic
voluntary civil associations like um the
girl scouts
totally gutted by these geniuses how
about our schools
i also very briefly touched on this on
friday but
i can't i can't let this one go without
a little mention
the missouri a missouri school district
right now
francis howell school district in saint
charles county missouri
has just hired a critical race theory
professor
to audit their curricula
the school district is paying this race
hustling huckster
this con artist fifteen thousand dollars
to ruin their history curriculum and to
imbue it with the ideology of critical
race theory
i mentioned this so that the the
hustler's name is dr
legarrette king he was hired for quote
professional development and
consultation services
and he's an associate professor at
university of missouri
and director of the university's carter
center for k-12 black history education
do not let them tell you that your kids
are not being
taught by critical race theory in
schools this is what's happening
king this hustler who was hired just by
one school district
one place has retweeted a lot of content
expressing his belief that critical race
theory ought to be taught in k-12
schools as well
he has now been hired by the school
district or was hired some time ago
to imbue the curriculum with this
radical theory
that our genius ruling elite tells us is
only taught in certain law schools
oh you idiots you rubes you idiot
percentage
it's this isn't being taught in schools
well here you go here you have a
critical race theorist who has been
hired by a school district k
through 12 to view the curriculum with
these ideas he is telling you
outright that he thinks that these sorts
of things should be taught in schools
and it's now happening don't let them
gaslight you
the ruling class gutted civic civic
civic association civil society
gutted the educational system
now this ruling elite is
instructing students to hate their own
country
which brings me to the olympics
the olympia i don't watch the olympics i
don't i've never really cared for the
olympics and i
haven't watched it in years but i did
see this clip
this clip that the olympic ceremony
opened with that anthem of
the brilliant genius global citizens of
the world
that awful twaddle by john lennon one of
the worst songs ever written
[Music]
imagine
and the world will live
and the world
[Music]
will lead
[Music]
is
[Music]
well i did not expect to see the voices
keith urban
here is part of the opening ceremony but
that was spectacular
i did not expect to hear that song that
they play every year since uh
you know 50 years ago and that the aged
boomer hippies
think he's the most important him in the
liturgical
calendar and and in our hymnal i did
expect it because they do it all the
time
it's awful it the vision of society that
it presents is just communism
imagine there's no god imagine there's
no heaven imagine there's nothing to
live for imagine there's no
distinctions between people or anything
that makes you special it's awful it's a
ugly hideous inhuman vision of society
and that's the vision the ruling elite
wants to push on you
you know the authoritarian moment comes
out tomorrow tuesday
july 27th you can get your limited
edition
signed book now for just 30 at
dailywire.com
ben ben will also be doing a live stream
book signing
and q a tomorrow and you can submit a
question for it right now when you go to
purchase your signed copy that is
dailywire.com to get your
signed copy today it's very important to
have this book so that you can cut out
the cover of it and use it as my
campaign sticker for 2028 knowles the
authoritarian moment
we just launched by the way our newest
podcast morning wire
it's already the number two podcast on
apple it's number 11 podcast on spotify
subscribe right now to morning wire on
apple podcast spotify anywhere else you
listen your podcasts
so that you do not miss a beat if you
like what you hear leave a five star
review
tell the podcast platforms that
conservative news belongs at number one
on the charts we'll be right back with a
lot more
i love that the olympics opened with
imagine i love it in part because i
don't watch the olympics so i didn't
have to endure that awful song by john
lennon
but i love it because it's an
acknowledgement that
the liberal ruling class the sort of
globalized
citizen of the world class doesn't have
any new ideas they've been playing the
same
damn song forever and i loved at the end
of this
of the broadcast the the broadcaster
said
wow i did not expect that that's not a
knife this isn't
i don't know my australian's not very
good and so the
broadcaster said that just a little trip
back through memory lane
they play this song almost every year
here we go london 2012
wow so inspiring
[Music]
imagine there's no heaven
pyeongchang 2018. imagine there's no
heaven imagine you turn to worm food
when you die
torino 2006.
above us just this physical world and
we're all going to just turn to
take a dirt nap when we die 96 in
atlanta
there wow inspiring imagine
imagine all the people living for their
own hedonistic pleasure
with nothing that is permanent wow
i was reading uh chesterton last night
gk chester the great
great british catholic writer and he
pointed out that the carpe diem religion
seize the day live for today the carpe
diem religion is not
the religion of happy people it's the
religion of very
unhappy people and we all know this in
our own
life we know that that friend of yours
who all he's ever doing is chasing
momentary pleasure
no regrets you regret the things you
don't do or whatever
that guy is never your happiest friend
paradoxically strangely
counter-intuitively according to
many people it tends to be
the well-grounded moderate
religious people who have a family who
practice the virtues who reign in their
own passions
they tend to be happier isn't that weird
isn't that strange thing it's
counterintuitive but it's not of course
the carpe diem religion the seize the
day we're only living for today there's
no heaven there's nothing above us
we're just just this world that religion
which is the
dominant view of the liberal ruling
class
is a desperate religion just try it's
the same problem that
i don't know if you've ever experienced
this but on a holiday very often
tensions are very high when you're going
over your family for a holiday
or valentine's day is a lot like this
where
you're so focused on having a good time
you're so
intent you think the day will be ruined
if you don't have a good time that you
never have a good time if you focus like
that
if you just take the day as it will if
you take life as it will if you
recognize that life involves a great
deal of suffering
and but there is a point to it and that
actually
there there is an enobling aspect of
this suffering and there's something
beyond just this physical world if you
recognize that
then it sanctifies everything it makes
it much more
comfortable much more bearable but if
all you're focused on is pleasuring
yourself all the time you
are going to be miserable i know it
seems counterintuitive
people are waking up to that i think a
lot of the revolt against our ruling
elite
is recognizing that the things that
they've promised us have not panned out
we were told women were told
that if they just stopped raising
families and went out to work for
some old guy at the widget factory 100
hours a week that that would make them
happier and it hasn't
the measures of this it's hard to
measure happiness but
such as they are these measures have
shown that isn't true women's happiness
is declined dramatically
if we just tell our kids
to you know pursue their own ambitions
and interests and our own ambitions and
interests and without
regard to a classical serious education
they'll be happier they're not they're
more stressed they're more anxious and
suicidal than ever
if we just let the liberal ruling elite
ship our jobs overseas yeah we'll lose
our job at the factory but it's okay
because gdp will increase and we'll have
more gizmos from china and that'll make
us all happier will it no we've got
deaths of despair going through the roof
we're actually seeing a reduction in
american life expectancy we've got an
opioid crisis
running amok well if we just empower
international organizations and empower
china
then the world is going to live in peace
is it i don't know we just had a global
pandemic allegedly
that you know the worst deadliest
pandemic ever but regardless of the
of the lethality of the virus we shut
down the whole world how'd that work out
didn't work out very well at all and i
think people are waking up to this and
they're saying
oh god they've these people have ruined
my country
the religion of imagine the religion of
imagine that nothing matters other than
our own pleasure and bumping up gdp
and suppressing the idiot percentage and
just following this this ruling class
wherever they want to lead us
that hasn't panned out very well and so
i think the trump vote was in many ways
a reaction against that
and i think you're only seeing that
increase the candidacies right now of jd
vance and blake masters the two senate
candidates
who are who are really contradicting a
lot of conservative orthodoxy who are
saying hey we need to forget about gdp
for a second we need to focus on
families
we need to focus on building up our
society we need to cut it out with all
this insane free quote unquote free
trade
that's really primarily benefiting other
countries we need to stop that
that is part of the reaction against
this
no surprise that the olympics just
really you know now the total expression
of the ruling global elite
is collapsing in the rating 16.7 million
americans tuned in to nbc's broadcast
this is the smallest television audience
in the past 33 years
it was predicted that the ratings could
drop as low as 17
million people in america and it dropped
even lower than that this is according
to preliminary data
from nbc universal now part of this
is that people don't watch tv as much
anymore certainly that's part of it
people are unplugging their tvs
they don't have cable although it's
worth pointing out this isn't this is a
network tv
so many many more people will have
network than would have cable
but sure part of it is the technological
issue
part of it is just this
vision of society is
is collapsing under under its own weight
steep steep drop the tokyo audience
declined 37
from 2016. 20
37 rather speaking of
two top pga golfers are not being
permitted to
compete in the olympics because they
tested positive for the wu flu
they weren't sick they're totally fine
but they tested positive
so now they can't compete spanish golfer
john rom
he tested positive last month i had to
drop out of a pga tournament that he was
leading
in by the way uh he's tested positive
again he won't he won't compete in tokyo
got this guy man he can't win for losing
he's he's got permanent covid
and uh bryson deshambo and american will
also miss the games because he tested
positive
for kovid insane you're now seeing more
travel restrictions around the world
because the global elite are clamping
down again
they say it's for the delta variant it's
the now we have the delta variant soon
we're gonna have the lambda variant then
we're gonna have the phi beta kappa
variant there's no end to the variance
folks
i don't know if you've caught on yet but
15 days to slow the spread is eternity
it's
it's never ending it is never ending
unless you take it back right now there
are 100 000 people in the streets
in paris to protest the french president
macron's new rules new lockdown rules
they're just going to keep this going
forever because they think it's better
for society they think it's better if
the scientific elite
has much more control than the people do
over society
and by the way they think it's better if
we just wear masks all the time i've
talked to
even slightly conservative public health
experts who have said well you know the
thing about the masks is maybe we don't
wear them all the time
but we should at least wear them during
flu season i mean it was crazy before
we were just going out and interacting
with one another and seeing our faces
and
that was crazy i think they want us to
do i think they want us to live
in this sanitized
hideous culture where we don't see one
another's faces where we don't have
many political rights and where the
vouchers of the world tell us what to do
where top athletes in the world are
taken out of the olympics because they
don't even have symptoms
from the wu flu that has been with us
now for a year year and a half vaccines
all over the place having
having many many harmful effects on
society
do you remember last year when
the federal government was proposing
a relief package for kovid i was fine
with the
relief package i sort of thought if the
government is going to shut down the
world
then the government owes you something
they can't just expect you to bear the
brunt of that
entirely if they're going to make this
ridiculous decision to shut down the
world
but i said you know the beefing up of
unemployment benefits that's a bad idea
covet stimulus fine by me the government
broke it the government can fix it
but the the beefing up of unemployment
is going to have really bad effects and
so some republicans
tried to fight very hard against this in
the senate i remember senator cruz and
senator graham
lindsey graham pushed very hard against
this but didn't go anywhere
so they it ended up going through well
now we have a report out from morning
consult
that 1.8 million americans
have turned down job offers in order to
stay on unemployment
now that's not good right that's that's
a bad situation i
i already knew this was the case not 1.8
million that's a shocking number but i
already knew this was a problem
because i've talked to my uber drivers
who say yeah you know a lot of there
aren't that many drivers right now
because people don't want to go back to
work because they're making more money
on unemployment
because i've talked to people in
restaurants who are waitresses
or managers or even owners of
restaurants and they'll say yeah i can't
we can't get staff here because people
are making more money on unemployment
well here's
from morning console you know it's not
like this is a far-right organization
they're reporting 1.8 million americans
would rather stay on the dole
because the ruling class
did something so obviously economically
and socially harmful
but those of us who said we're the idiot
percentage who said maybe this isn't a
good idea
speaking of people getting jobs i'm
going to add i'm going to rub salt in
that wound right now
because the ruling class still has a ton
of power and they're flexing
that power you know one of the
highlights of the trump administration
was that trump got a lot of judges
through and they
often were disappointing judges but
still there were a number of good judges
who got through i'm not just talking
about the supreme court i'm talking
about
the lower courts as well she said all
right trump and cocaine mitch they're
getting
judges through at record rates
joe biden is blowing them out of the
water right now
in the first six months of his
administration
joe biden and the democrats have had
eight
federal judges confirmed that is
the highest number of judges confirmed
not just in the last four
or eight or 12 or 16 years highest
number of judges confirmed
in 52 years more than half a century
trump and george h.w bush at this point
in their presidency
had each appointed four judges obama
bush ii and ronald reagan hadn't
appointed any
biden's already gotten eight federal
judges through
the guy does not know which end is up
the guy
probably doesn't know his own name
but but the establishment is still
wielding political power in a pretty
effective way it's a harmful way for our
country
it's going to lead to more more and more
misery into a greater collapse
of our civil order but they're they're
pretty good at wielding political power
you know speaking of the judges there is
a huge court case that's coming up this
term this is the dobbs
case the dobbs case at regards an
abortion law
whether or not it is legal to
limit abortion or prohibit abortion
after 15 weeks this is the point at
which a baby can suck his own thumb
and this case will seek to overturn roe
versus wade and planned parenthood v
casey
well i think joe biden just accidentally
touched on this case joe biden
uh there are a number of clips of him
going around that are pretty
embarrassing i'm not even going to play
one of them on the show though
it's gone viral the clip
the clip is uh joe biden screaming
something that seems as though he's
referring to his own anatomy and it's
just really it's one of these bizarre
outbursts that biden has made but there
are a number of them
out there including he was asked a
question are democrats
are there democrats who want to defund
the police joe biden has a puzzling
answer
we are not defunding the police
[Music]
are there people in the republican party
you think we're sucking the blood out of
kids
i i i'm i'm not sure are there people in
the democratic party who want us
are there p are you defunding the
polices are the people in the republican
party you think we're sucking the blood
out of kids which just as a as a
practical matter just as a very narrow
matter the democrats are by supporting
abortion
but the broader point is even more
preposterous
joe biden says we're not defunding the
police
oh the republicans next they're going to
say we're sucking the blood out of kids
which we
are through abortion which we're
vigorously defending which i'm actually
trying to get taxpayers to fund right
now through the repeal of the hyde
amendment
okay neither here nor there
republicans when they say that democrats
want to defund the police
they're not making some outlandish claim
they're not they're not coming up with
some conspiracy theory as joe biden is
implying
they're just quoting the democrats own
words very very prominent
democratic politicians have said defund
the police
i've called to defund the police have
put forward legislation to have
have successfully defunded the police
and very prominent democratic
politicians have said
abolish the police doesn't mean just
move some funding around or change the
training it means abolish the police it
means get rid of them
but joe biden makes them oh what's next
what do you what are you people going to
say next you say we're sucking the blood
out of kids
they can't even stand by their own words
because they can see how deeply
unpopular they are
because they can see that people are
waking up to what
this ruling class has done to them
we sucking the blood out of kids i mean
we are but
speaking of our culture's abuse of young
people
you know i bring up tick-tock videos
somewhat frequent
only the ones that kind of go viral and
make make their way around the internet
i'm not on tik-tok myself i
feel that xi jinping has enough of my
information but i do catch it on twitter
or youtube sometimes
so there was a video of a young person
describing the difference between i want
to get this right
between aromanticism
and asexuality these are now two sexual
identities and and so one
is aromantic you're not roman and the
other is asexual here's the difference
this is a reminder that non-asexual
aromantic
and allosexual aromantic are not always
interchangeable
non-asexual aromantic includes
identities such as my own
i'm not asexual but i'm not allosexual
either
my experiences are going to be very
different from an allosexual aromantic
person's
i think it's just important if you're an
ally who's talking about aromantic
issues
if you're talking about allosexual
aromantic issues
make sure to say allosexual aromantic
there's nothing wrong with that term
just saying
non-asexual aromantic also includes
other aromantic people who might
not experience sexual attraction but
still don't identify as asexual
just something to keep in mind that is
something that if you keep it in your
mind your mind will turn to soup
i don't i want to be pretty clear by the
way
i am not poking fun at this
confused young person's idea of
sexuality
i am actually indignant and
outraged by the way that our culture has
warped this young person's mind and
confused
this young person i'm not not exactly
clear i don't want to be
wrong about identities and the aloe and
the amo and the whatever this
the identities are so i googled it i
googled the aromantic and
i don't know what aloe is but arrow i
saw is
a aromantic that's the lingo for
aromantic and it means you're not
romantically attracted to people but you
do enjoy having sex with them sometimes
possibly
and then asexual is you don't enjoy
having sex with people
but you may be romantically attracted to
them
how does that work i don't no nobody
knows nobody nobody knows but this these
are just
two of the newer sexual identities there
will probably be a half dozen more by
the time we finish this show today and
there aren't that
that many more minutes left in the show
but there will still be more of these
things
because getting back to the point on uh
race that the girl scouts brought up you
know that
racial blindness colorblindness is
actually
awful because it erases people's
identity
if your identity as a culture
is in the font of being you know i am
that i am god is another name for him
uh then you you will know who you are
and you will have a fixed point that you
are
moving toward and that that you are
identifying yourself with if you do not
you will be as my
friend father george rutler has pointed
out if you do not i find your identity
in the i
am who i am you will find your identity
with this v
or you will attempt to find your
identity with a pathetic question which
is who am i
you'll say i'm an elo a row [ __ ] a sex
trans bi none whatever and you'll it
will never end it will never end because
you are not sufficient because you are a
contingent being
who is imperfect because this is a
fallen world
and you will never be satisfied with
your own identity will just go on and on
and on
on wednesday on last wednesday argentina
decided to indulge this insanity at the
governmental level
they are now incorporating
identification cards that include an
option for people who do not identify as
either
female or male they will allow people to
put x
in their national identification
document and passports
in the place where they otherwise would
have put their sex
now obviously this undermines the point
of identification documents
is you won't actually be identifying
yourself but i want to
show you the three opinions on this
there's the leftist opinion which is you
you have a god-given well they don't
believe in god but you that you have a
human right or whatever
to gender expression and identifying
however you want to add and you
absolutely have the right to put the x
on your gender
form then there is the kind of squishy
conservative libertarian thing which is
they'll say look you have a right
you have every right to identify as a
transgender person or a binary or an
arrow halo whatever whatever it is
but just don't make me pay for it right
or just
but you can't put it on a document or
maybe you can but your kid can't
do it but your kids can't do it that's
off limit for kids or they'll try to put
some contrived limitations
on it while still granting the premise
of
a right to infinite personal autonomy to
indulge whatever delusion you have and
then there's the conservative response
which is
you don't have a right to define reality
in justice kennedy's words you don't
have the even though he was obviously on
the other side of the question
but you don't have the right to define
your own concept of existence there is
reality it will reassert itself in the
end
and you must bend your
absolute tyranny of will you have to you
have to bend it toward reality
eventually you cannot impose
your delusions on the world and you
don't know it doesn't matter your age
doesn't matter
you're how nice you are or whatever you
cannot you do not have a right to
contradict reality
and i think unfortunately our genius
elite has been denying reality for a
long time and a lot of squishes
who might have had very good intentions
have been have
to some degree indulged that belief and
i think
the american people the the idiot
percentage the rest of us
you know us crazy idiots who think that
men are not women and foreigners are not
americans and who recognize that the
ruling elite has led us off a cliff
we are saying no we're on the side of
reality
your fantasies haven't worked take a
seat
and we need to take political power back
from those people
who who view us with nothing but
derision
and and who who view us as as
incompetent bumbling deplorable fools
who by the way can govern society a
whole lot better i suspect than our
ruling elite i'm michael knows us the
michael nola show i'll see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy bourie our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here editor-in-chief of
daily wire
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire
on today's episode the biden
administration signals a push for
renewed mask mandates and vaccine
boosters
australia erupts in protests after
another round of lockdowns
and the nfl experiences blow back to its
new vaccine rules
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire
[Music]